morad el hattab bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
la turquie a dénoncé aujourd'hui on le
disait elle approche destructrice de la
france en libye à l'accusant de chercher
à renforcer la présence de la russie à
quoi précisément ankara fait référence
oui
ankara fait référence au fait que déjà
en janvier 2001 est là francs à ankara
va taxer la france dax du mal en vrai
cette passe d'armes a déjà eu lieu au
mois de janvier et l'histoire se répète
mais les maquereaux avait tenu les mêmes
propos à la conférence de berlin fin
janvier 2020 et en quarts avait déjà
répondu de la même manière
donc j'ai presque métier l histoire se
répète quoi alors des propos d' emmanuel
macron qui accuse lui la turquie d'avoir
une responsabilité historique et
criminels dans ce conflit avec ces mots
que reproche le président français aux
turcs pas ils reprochent aux turcs
kurdes et au rafale avait constaté le 29
janvier 2020 et c'est que la turquie a
mené sur le sol libyen des blindés
lourds et des mercenaires jihadistes
donc elles violaient l'embargo
pour ce faire et il est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui la turquie profite
militairement d'une avancée sur le
terrain pour caen dira avoir une assise
sur le territoire les biens aussi bien
au niveau des zones maritimes que
maintenant sur les réseaux être les
faire puisque la turquie a obtenu le
droit de forer des hydrocarbures par le
biais de sa rage
alors vous le disiez ces passes d'armes
ne date pas d'aujourd'hui est ce que les
relations entre la france et la turquie
pourraient davantage dégénéré selon vous
oui elles vont dégénérer
mais le conflit va se passer sur un
autre terrain henry était aujourd'hui la
france
malheureusement les plus crédibles est
ce que vous voulez savoir qu'il ya des
tensions actuellement entre le quai
d'orsay et le ministère de la défense
français
qui ne parle pas d'une même voix et ça
les pays étrangers le savent
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui compte c'est
l'intervention quand un train de
s'organiser
c'est à dire quelle voie différente
entre le quai d'orsay et le ministère de
la défense
bah le quai d'orsay
essai de normaliser les relations que sa
rage alors que le ministère de la
défense compte appui à nouveau haftar
dans le temps avec effectivement les
émirats arabes unis l'arabie saoudite et
un peu la russie et l'arabie saoudite
effectivement c'est ce qui va se passer
moi je vous garantis que dans un avenir
proche les forces militaires égyptiennes
vont intervenir directement en libye
et effectivement à ce moment là ce sera
tout un autre scénario et il va y avoir
une sorte de normalisation des relations
qui vont s'établir avec je pense une
future rencontre à moscou où sarah jaf
d'art seront invités pour normaliser la
situation en permettant éventuellement
la fusion des institutions et l'adoption
d'une déclaration constitutionnelle mais
nous la france tenait hors jeu et de
trop de pays qui réalise que on ne parle
pas d'une seule voix
ça peut pas continuer et côté turc quel
est l'intérêt un du pays de s'impliquer
à ce point aux côtés du gouvernement
d'union nationale de fayez elle sa rage
alors c'est une certaine questions très
pertinentes effectivement puisque c'est
un avantage énorme que détient la russie
aujourd'hui depuis les accords qu'elle
assigne à quel sa rage puisque elle a
une entrée directe en mer méditerranée
ce que aujourd'hui provoque l'ire et la
colère de chypre de la grèce d'israël et
bientôt du liban l'egypte est aussi
comme je vous le dis un ancrage direct
ça va permettre aussi à la rue à la à la
turquie d'erdogan d'avoir la main sur
une bonne partie de la zone sahélienne
les rapports liés à l'immigration les
rapports liés aux zones pétrolifères
r aux zones maritimes donc pour erdogan
c'est un coup de maître par contre elle
s'arrache je peux vous assurer qu'il est
complètement discrédité auprès du peuple
libyen
car il a carrément donné la tutelle de
zone géostratégique un pays tiers
merci beaucoup moins la table d'avoir
partagé votre expertise sur rt frange
rappelle que vous êtes écrivain les
géopolitologue